thank you
my days suck yeah yep
just trying to
hey I need you to get the paperwork
rolling on a new workplace relationship
for you yes for Gabe who are you seeing
that's good whom I'm seeing is Val from
down in the warehouse I'm not
technically seeing her but uh I've seen
her with the eyes and there was
attraction in at least One Direction so
you know I don't have to do paperwork
unless you're actually dating okay but
once this starts it's going to be moving
fast it's going to be hot and heavy and
I don't want a bunch of bureaucratic
grid tape wrapped around my jock you
know but I mean have you talked to her
yeah we had a whole conversation about
Mondays
do you know her last name yeah Toby I'm
going to tell you her last name tomorrow
because she's going to be screaming it
tonight she's going to be screaming her
own last name hey
watch it
good luck game
hi I'm Kevin
where'd you find her
at the gym
right
the gym
one two
[Applause]
Toby
[Music]
two times seven nickels and one well
okay no that doesn't happen it was one
quarter and
what I was just explaining what but why
wouldn't it be
Are You Gonna Kiss Me
yes
thank you
well
apparently
Michael Scott is on a date
and that
my friend changes everything
hey you're supposed to hit the white
ball first buddy
all right
all right everything okay why are you
wearing a hat now guys come on I'm on a
date let me do my thing hi I'm date Mike
nice to meet me how do you like your
eggs in the morning
[Applause]
hey guys guys
what are you doing I'm trying to not
understand with my chocolate not to do
this
I would say I kind of have an unfair
Advantage because I watch reality dating
shows like Hawk and I learn I absorb
information from the strategies of the
winners and the losers actually I
probably learned more from the losers
thanks for walking me out oh my pleasure
yeah there's all kinds of weirdos out
here so you must be freezing I am about
to die
will you wait here while I go get my
jacket but no it's okay this is my car
okay okay well listen
you're a new client and as one of my new
clients you will always be taken care of
and that is the nard dog guarantee
what's a nard dog this is the nerd dog
whoa what the hell oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh I I thought we had this energy and
I'm a mess and I just had my heart
broken and you came in today and you're
so pretty you're like incredible I just
got out of a relationship too it's
really hard yeah right
do you want to talk like go to a mall or
mall or something to walk around I don't
think so sure yeah that's you're right
that's too soon
for definitely too soon for me
so I'm glad we got that out of the way
I'm gonna be in touch with you in three
months I'm gonna call you about that
order
and maybe about that mall walk okay
take care Julia thank you
sorry I tried to kiss you
we lost the account
hi when
I'm just gonna say to you everything
that I'm thinking okay I think you have
the best smile
I'd like to take you out to dinner and a
movie
okay
now you look at me like you're adoring
me and I'm gonna let the camera like I
don't even know you're there I do adore
you
I thought I was gonna be hanging out
with Stanley on this trip
but he's turned out to be kind of a
loose cannon my friend and I knew here
in Tallahassee would you like to get a
cocktail maybe go out for a little dance
and beautiful day now
I got too much ice cream you want some
getting my Fry on
the Moon is huge tonight oh gosh the
moon one's damning yeah sorry that's
regular text talk you forgot one you're
such a great friend with the dots you're
such a great friend dot dot dot dot
five dots Daryl are you kidding me okay
because three knots means to be
continued four dots is a typo but five
dots means whoa do not make me say what
I want to say baby but if I did it would
blow your mind dot dot dot dot dot yes
thank you sister Brandon Daryl and me
it's ridiculous right yeah totally crazy
puts me in an insane asylum just
thinking about it I'm stranded on
Shutter Island over here
hey
I just wanted to apologize I mean that
was so weird can we just like never talk
about it again sure
just so you know me and you
I don't think that's ridiculous
dot dot dot
dot dot
about 10 minutes ago
no I didn't know what to say
yes I know
um
I don't know Mom he's my best friend
yeah he's great
yeah I think I am
um I have to go I will
listen Jim
you have no idea how long I wanted to do
that
me too
I think we're just drunk
are you drunk
no
gym
you're really gonna marry him
okay
oh air hockey basketball we could play
that oh whack-a-mole brothers or sisters
Three Brothers really so we're in the
Marines one's a cup vegetarian
no I love meat
what's your blood type oh negative
universal donor universal donor
hahaha
all right